This is the 99% Invisible City. I'm Roman Mars. For the first time in a long time, I'm in our office in beautiful downtown, Oakland, California. A couple people actually still work here. Two people can occupy the space without violating any social distancing guidelines, there's two entrances, there's two different bathrooms, there's two different kitchens. I usually work at home, but today I'm here because our first book, the 99% Invisible City has just been released into the world. Since it's a guide to the city with stories and histories of the seemingly mundane things around you. My co-author, Kirk Olsett and I, are gonna use it to explore all the everyday objects right outside our own headquarters.
这里是《99%隐形城市》（99% Invisible City）。我是罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。在经历了很长一段时间后，我终于回到了我们位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的办公室。其实还有几个人在这里工作。两个人可以在不违反任何社交距离准则的情况下使用这个空间，这里有两个入口，两个不同的洗手间，两个不同的厨房。我通常在家工作，但今天我在这里，因为我们的第一本书《99%隐形城市》刚刚向世界发布。这是一本关于城市的指南，讲述了你周围看似平凡的事物的历史和故事。我和我的合著者柯克·奥尔斯特德（Kirk Olsett）将利用它来探索我们总部外面的所有日常物品。
But before we even leave the office, just looking at the window, there's a brick building next door, and the tops of its walls are dotted with a bunch of square metal plates. These anchor plates are a few inches across. They're pretty thin, and they're spun in a bunch of square metal plates. These anchor plates are a few inches across. They're pretty thin and they're spun in a bunch of different orientations. So even though they're painted to blend in with the brick, once you notice them,
但在我们离开办公室之前，只要看看窗外，隔壁有一栋砖砌建筑，墙顶上点缀着一堆方形金属板。这些锚固板有几英寸宽。它们很薄，以各种不同的方向旋转。所以即使它们被漆成与砖块融为一体，一旦你注意到它们，
they kind of stand out. And you could think of them like giant washers with bolts or rods tying them into the bricks and helping brace them against the facade. And these ones happen to be square, but I've seen others in the neighborhood that are round or octagonal. In fact, anchor plates like this are pretty common in the Bay Area in part for seismic reasons. They help make sure that loose bricks don't fall off buildings and hurt people during
它们就会显得很突出。你可以把它们想象成巨大的垫圈，用螺栓或杆子将它们固定在砖块上，并帮助支撑外墙。这些正好是方形的，但我还在附近见过圆形的或八角形的。事实上，像这样的锚固板在湾区很常见，部分原因是地震因素。它们有助于确保松动的砖块在地震期间不会从建筑物上掉下来伤人。
earthquakes. These particular ones are way up high where the walls overrun the roof, so there's a parapet up there where the bricks can't be braced against the main building. And so someone installed these and connected them to middle braces on the rooftop that you can't actually see from below. In other places though, you can't actually see from below. In other places though, you can see anchor plates all the way down a facade, and in those cases they have a ton of work to do. They help hold up entire masonry walls that might otherwise be at risk of total collapse. In the book, we have an illustration with a bunch of different shapes that you can look
这些特殊的锚固板位于墙壁高出屋顶的地方，所以那里有一个女儿墙，砖块无法靠在主体建筑上。因此，有人安装了这些锚固板，并将它们连接到屋顶上的金属支架上，你在下面实际上是看不到的。但在其他地方，你可以看到锚固板一直延伸到外墙底部，在这种情况下，它们承担了大量的工作。它们有助于支撑整个砖石墙，否则这些墙可能会面临完全倒塌的风险。在书中，我们有一张插图，展示了你可以留意到的各种不同形状，
out for in whatever city you're in. There are squares and circles and stars and other geometric forms, but there are also some really ornate ones, like this huge curving-esque shape that holds up an old stone wall in Europe. But whether they look good or not so good, they've got a job to do, and they all look better than the alternative, which would be, of course see a beautiful black ornate fire escape. I love that we have a fire escape on our building.
无论你在哪个城市。有正方形、圆形、星形和其他几何形状，但也有一些非常华丽的，比如欧洲用来支撑古老石墙的巨大弯曲形状。但无论它们看起来好不好看，它们都有自己的工作要做，而且它们看起来都比替代方案要好，当然，替代方案就是看到一个漂亮的黑色华丽消防梯。我很高兴我们的建筑上有消防梯。
I know a couple people on the staff that climb out on it and they watch the city at night. I never do that because I'm a big chicken. Fire has long been one of the greatest existential threats to a building in its occupants, but fire escapes became widespread kind of late in the game. Back in the 1700s, fire escapes weren't built in features, but rather mobile ladders on carts hauled two blazes by firemen. Other solutions for escaping a fire in a multi-story building in the 1800s included parachute hats.
我知道有几个员工会爬上去，在晚上观察城市。我从来不敢这样做，因为我胆子很小。长期以来，火灾一直是建筑物及其居住者面临的最大生存威胁之一，但消防梯的普及其实比较晚。早在18世纪，消防梯并不是建筑的内置功能，而是消防员用马车拉到火灾现场的移动梯子。19世纪多层建筑中逃离火灾的其他解决方案包括降落伞帽。
I think you can imagine both how those looked and how they did not work at all. There was even this widely circulated plan that proposed that if there was a fire that archers from the ground would shoot arrows with ropes attached to them for residents on the upper floors to shimmy down. But eventually, we settled on iron fire escapes attached permanently to a building's facade. Fire escapes are thankfully not used very often, but unfortunately, this also means that they can fall into this repair, especially if a landlord is prone to cutting corners. The infamous Triangle Shirt Ways Factory fire that killed 146 people in 1911 was a national tragedy that spurred a lot of change in terms of workers' rights, but it also made people
我想你可以想象它们看起来是什么样子，以及它们是如何完全不起作用的。甚至还有一个广为流传的计划，提议如果发生火灾，地面的弓箭手会射出带有绳索的箭，让高层的居民顺着绳子滑下来。但最终，我们选择了永久固定在建筑外墙上的铁制消防梯。值得庆幸的是，消防梯并不经常使用，但不幸的是，这也意味着它们可能会失修，特别是如果房东倾向于偷工减料的话。1911年造成146人死亡的臭名昭著的三角内衣工厂火灾是一场全国性的悲剧，它在工人权利方面引发了许多变革，但也促使人们
look closely at how we need safe and plentiful means of egress from buildings in case of emergency. In this instance, one of the things that caused a lot of the deaths was that the fire escape collapsed under the weight of all the people trying to flee for their lives. Since then, and especially today, managing the flow of people during an emergency is a top consideration. It's still not perfect, obviously. If you look around the city, most buildings don't seem to have fire escapes anymore that
密切关注我们需要在紧急情况下从建筑物中获得安全且充足的出口方式。在这种情况下，导致大量死亡的原因之一是消防梯在所有试图逃命的人的重压下倒塌了。从那时起，特别是今天，在紧急情况下管理人员流动是一个首要考虑因素。显然，它仍然不完美。如果你环顾城市，大多数建筑物似乎不再有消防梯，
newer buildings never do, but looks can be deceiving. These buildings do have fire escapes, but they've be deceiving. These buildings, they do have fire escapes, but they've essentially been swallowed up by buildings, evolving into fortified stairs. Fire stairs often double as ordinary staircases used on a daily basis, but they have extra protections and features to make them safer routes of escape during emergencies, so you could be walking on the great granddaughter of this virus gate every day and not even noticing.
较新的建筑物从来没有，但外表可能会骗人。这些建筑物确实有消防梯，但它们本质上已经被建筑物吞噬，演变成了加固的楼梯。消防楼梯通常兼作日常使用的普通楼梯，但它们有额外的保护和功能，使它们成为紧急情况下更安全的逃生路线，所以你每天可能都在走着这个消防梯的“曾孙”，甚至都没有注意到。
So right next door to our office, there's a storefront and the businesses inside it and if they have changed over the years, but out front there's this persistent element and it's a planter and the planter is kind of recessed into the facade a bit so the edge of it, the front edge of it, is up against the sidewalk and the plants, dirt, are held in place by this low retaining wall that's maybe a couple inches deep and you know
就在我们办公室隔壁，有一家店面，里面的生意多年来换了好几茬，但门前有一个持久的元素，那就是一个花坛。花坛稍微凹进外墙，所以它的边缘，前缘，紧靠着人行道，植物和泥土被这堵低矮的挡土墙固定住，大约有几英寸深，你知道，
under the best of circumstances it wouldn't be a great place to sit, although I've seen people try. But what makes it really, really unappealing is this row of knobs that they have a raid along the top of the wall. And we've talked about things like spikes on the show before that dissuade people from sitting. But these knobs, they look almost decorative.
在最好的情况下，它也不是一个坐着的好地方，尽管我见过有人尝试。但真正让它非常、非常不吸引人的是墙顶上排列的一排旋钮。我们之前在节目中讨论过像尖刺这样的东西，可以阻止人们坐下。但这些旋钮看起来几乎是装饰性的。
Like, they're painted black to blend in with the black wall. They're defensive design, but like in disguise. And when we think about things like defensive design or hostile architecture, we tend to imagine obvious things, like spikes, but there are a lot of less obvious ones too. Some places have sprinkler systems that are situated to keep people away rather than to actually water plants. And in Seattle there's this one bike rack in particular
它们被漆成黑色，与黑色的墙壁融为一体。它们是防御性设计，但像是伪装起来的。当我们想到防御性设计或敌对建筑时，我们倾向于想象明显的东西，比如尖刺，但也有很多不那么明显的东西。有些地方有喷水系统，其设置是为了让人远离，而不是为了给植物浇水。在西雅图，有一个自行车架特别
that's kind of infamous because people started to question why did somebody put a bike rack there? That's not a place people would normally park their bikes. And it turned out that this was put there by the city to keep people from setting up tents and camping on that particular stretch of sidewalk. And, you know, big picture, a lot of these interventions, they don't tackle bigger underlying issues. They just kind of shuffle people around.
臭名昭著，因为人们开始质疑为什么有人在那里放一个自行车架？那不是人们通常停放自行车的地方。结果发现，这是城市为了防止人们在那段人行道上搭帐篷露营而设置的。而且，你知道，从大局来看，许多这些干预措施并没有解决更大的潜在问题。它们只是把人赶来赶去。
And to me, that's a good argument for transparency among other things. Because when you disguise something, you stop conversations from starting around it. So once it's clear why something is the way it is, people can start to debate whether or not a given design, quote, unquote, solution is humane or equitable way it is. People can start to debate whether or not a given design quote-unquote solution is humane or equitable or even effective. Looking down on our street corner you'll see a bunch of spray painted marks on the road
对我来说，这是主张透明度的一个很好的理由。因为当你伪装某样东西时，你就阻止了围绕它展开的对话。所以一旦清楚了某样东西为什么是这样，人们就可以开始辩论给定的设计，所谓的“解决方案”，是否是人道的、公平的，甚至是有效的。俯瞰我们的街角，你会看到路上
and on the sidewalk. Here's a fun fact. The first two-page illustration in the book, located just before chapter 1, is an illustration of this very spot, Kurt took the picture from our window. The colorful spray-painted markings are a guide to all the pipes and wires and tubes crisscrossing below the surface, and they are there for a very important reason. In June of 1976, workers were excavating a stretch of venous boulevard in Los Angeles, California, and accidentally cut into a hidden petroleum pipeline. The pipe ruptured in pressurized gas,
和人行道上有许多喷漆标记。这里有一个有趣的事实。书中的第一张两页插图，位于第1章之前，就是这个地方的插图，柯克从我们的窗户拍下了这张照片。五颜六色的喷漆标记是地表下纵横交错的所有管道、电线和管线的指南，它们的存在有一个非常重要的原因。1976年6月，工人们在加利福尼亚州洛杉矶的一段维纳斯大道上挖掘时，不小心切断了一条隐藏的石油管道。管道破裂，加压气体
ignited into a fireball that engulfed passing cars and adjacent businesses. More than two dozen people were injured or killed. This wasn't the first or last tragedy of its kind, but the enormity of this particular disaster helped catalyze the codification of these color-coded utility markings. So in general, anyone excavating on public property is required to contact a regional alert organization before digging into the ground so that the different utility agencies can come out and mark the hazards that may be below.
点燃成火球，吞没了过往的车辆和邻近的企业。超过二十人受伤或死亡。这不是此类悲剧的第一次，也不会是最后一次，但这场特殊灾难的严重性有助于催化这些颜色编码的公用设施标记的编纂。因此，总的来说，任何在公共财产上挖掘的人在挖掘地面之前都必须联系区域警报组织，以便不同的公用事业机构可以出来标记下面可能存在的危险。
The American National Standards Institute has formalized which colors indicate which utility. So this is my favorite part. So red is for electrical power lines, orange is for telecommunications, yellow is for gaseous or combustive materials like natural gas or petroleum, green is for sewage lines, there are a few other colors, but there's some of the biggies. For some reason, an infinity symbol is used to indicate the beginning or end of a proposed project area, even though an infinity symbol is normally applied to things
美国国家标准协会已经正式规定了哪些颜色代表哪些公用设施。这是我最喜欢的部分。红色代表电力线，橙色代表电信，黄色代表气体或可燃材料，如天然气或石油，绿色代表污水管道，还有其他几种颜色，但这些是一些主要的。出于某种原因，无穷大符号被用来表示拟议项目区域的开始或结束，尽管无穷大符号通常应用于
without a beginning or an end. So obviously, some colors and symbols are more intuitive than others. But what I love about all this official graffiti is that for this stretch of concrete we all have x-ray vision if we know how to decode it. So on our block there's a relatively recent renovation that added a bunch of traffic coming devices, things like planters and ballards to him in the cars a bit and slow people down And to make it easier to cross the street and it's pretty good
没有开始或结束的事物。所以很明显，有些颜色和符号比其他的更直观。但我喜欢所有这些官方涂鸦的原因是，对于这段混凝土，如果我们知道如何解码，我们都有X光视力。所以我们的街区最近进行了一次翻新，增加了一堆交通稳静化装置，比如花坛和护柱，稍微限制了汽车，让人们慢下来，让过马路更容易，这相当不错。
But further up the street if you if you go up a bit there's a much more traditional and Classical and recognizable traffic coming feature a speed bump classical and recognizable traffic calming feature, a speed bump. And it's pretty typical. It looks like any other speed bump, it's just a raised stretch of pavement that goes across the lane, and it's meant to slow people down. And then the boat we write about, you know, a bunch of different traffic calming strategies. But there's one in particular that I really am into. And what it's called sort of depends on who you ask, but if you Google speed cushion, you'll get the right result. And what makes it special
但再往前走一点，如果你往上走一点，有一个更传统、更经典、更易识别的交通稳静化功能，减速带。它很典型。它看起来像任何其他减速带一样，只是横跨车道的一段凸起的路面，旨在让人们慢下来。在书中，我们写到了许多不同的交通稳静化策略。但我特别喜欢其中一种。它的名字取决于你问谁，但如果你谷歌搜索“减速垫”（speed cushion），你会得到正确的结果。是什么让它特别
is actually pretty simple. It's got these real-white slices cut through it. So if you see one, it actually looks more like three smaller speed bumps side-by-side. But why? Well, there's space to accommodate emergency speed bumps like ambulances. So for a normal driver of a normal car with normal wheel spacing, it still works like a speed bump. But for a driver rushing to save lives, they can breeze right through without slowing down. And honestly, it's pretty simple, but can breeze right through without slowing down. And honestly, it's pretty simple, but I think it's quite in genius. Okay, traffic lights.
其实很简单。它有这些真正的白色切片切过它。所以如果你看到一个，它实际上看起来更像三个并排的小减速带。但为什么呢？嗯，有空间容纳紧急车辆，比如救护车。所以对于一个开着普通汽车、轮距正常的普通司机来说，它仍然像减速带一样起作用。但对于一个急于救人的司机来说，他们可以轻松通过而无需减速。老实说，这很简单，但我认为它非常天才。好了，交通灯。
We already told you about the one in Syracuse, New York, with the green on top of the red as a symbol of Irish pride, but that isn't the only funky thing going on with traffic like colors in the world. In Japan, their green light is more of a bluish green, and this comes from the fact that they're interpretation of the color blue, or owl, let's say, ow, as they say. I mean, that's the best, I AO owl, as they say. I mean, that's the best I can say, as they say. The color owl historically encompasses hues that most English speakers in the west would call green.
我们已经告诉过你纽约州雪城的那一个，绿色在红色之上，作为爱尔兰自豪感的象征，但这并不是世界上交通灯颜色中唯一古怪的事情。在日本，他们的绿灯更偏向蓝绿色，这源于他们对蓝色（AO）的解释。我的意思是，这是我能说的最好的，正如他们所说。历史上，“AO”这个词涵盖了大多数西方英语使用者会称之为绿色的色调。
Japan was not a signatory to the Vienna conventions on road signs and signals, which was this multilateral treaty systematizing road signs, markings and lights across dozens of countries. And so for nearly 100 years, Japanese stoplights have been labeled blue on official documents, even though many languages would call the color they see on Japanese traffic lights green. So in order to cut down on international confusion, they came to a compromise.
日本不是《维也纳道路标志和信号公约》的签署国，这是一项将数十个国家的道路标志、标记和灯光系统化的多边条约。因此，近100年来，日本的红绿灯在官方文件上一直被标记为蓝色，尽管许多语言会称他们在日本红绿灯上看到的颜色为绿色。因此，为了减少国际上的困惑，他们达成了一个妥协。
In 1973, the government mandated that traffic lights use the blue-ish shade of green possible. So there's a color that is technically green, but blue enough to be called owl. So if you go to Japan, their green traffic lights may be more, you know, blue or bling, but still just keep moving along all as well. While we're in the headspace of Japan by way of Oakland, I want to tell you about the manhole covers of Osaka. Oh my god, they're beautiful. The Oakland manhole covers in our neighborhood are so boring and comparison to those in Osaka.
1973年，政府规定交通灯使用尽可能偏蓝的绿色。所以有一种颜色在技术上是绿色，但足够蓝，可以被称为“AO”。所以如果你去日本，他们的绿灯可能更偏向蓝色，但没关系，继续走，一切都好。当我们通过奥克兰进入日本的思维空间时，我想告诉你大阪的井盖。天哪，它们太美了。我们社区的奥克兰井盖与大阪的相比太无聊了。
There's one that looks like an ornate woodblock print showing Osaka castle wrapped in blue waves and white cherry blossoms. And fancy covers dot streets all over the country with pictures of flowers, animals, buildings, and bridges, boats, and mythical heroes, rising phoenixes. These artistic covers gained popularity in the 1980s when a government bureaucrat named Yasutaki Kameda proposed them as a way to raise awareness of the awesomeness of municipal sewer systems and make no mistake municipal sewer systems are awesome. No one
有一个看起来像华丽的木版画，展示了包裹在蓝色波浪和白色樱花中的大阪城。精致的井盖点缀在全国各地的街道上，上面有花朵、动物、建筑物、桥梁、船只、神话英雄和凤凰的图案。这些艺术井盖在20世纪80年代流行起来，当时一位名叫龟田康隆（Yasutaki Kameda）的政府官僚提议将它们作为提高人们对市政下水道系统卓越性认识的一种方式，别搞错了，市政下水道系统非常棒。没有人
should need to be convinced of that. But he wanted to levied more taxes to improve and expand the sewer network and so the fancy covers were the focus of a visibility and appreciation campaign. He even encouraged different cities to compete over who had the best lids. Now you could easily spend a good hour marveling at Japanese manhole covers online. In fact, I encourage you to do just that. These Oakland ones though they kinda suck, but ones, though, they kind of suck. But municipal water systems, they're still amazing. So if there's one thing I always notice when I walk around downtown Oakland,
应该需要被说服。但他想征收更多的税来改善和扩大下水道网络，所以这些精致的井盖是一场知名度和欣赏运动的焦点。他甚至鼓励不同的城市竞争谁拥有最好的井盖。现在，你可以在网上花上整整一个小时惊叹于日本的井盖。事实上，我鼓励你这样做。不过这些奥克兰的井盖有点糟糕，但市政供水系统仍然很棒。所以如果说我在奥克兰市中心走动时总是注意到一件事，
it's this giant array of stuff on top of this tall building, a few blocks from our office. And it's hard to tell from far away and from down on the ground. But these things are huge, like the size of SUVs. They're curved at the top and the tapers they go down and they face in various directions. But what are they? Well, they're microwave relay towers and their vestiges of this really remarkable technology from the mid-1950s.
那就是离我们办公室几个街区的一栋高楼顶上有一大堆东西。从远处和地面上很难分辨。但这些东西很大，像SUV那么大。它们顶部弯曲，向下逐渐变细，并且朝向不同的方向。但它们是什么？嗯，它们是微波中继塔，是20世纪50年代中期这种非常了不起的技术的遗迹。
Back in the 1950s, AT&T engaged in this huge nationwide construction project. The company deployed a whole network of these relays across the country. And sure, okay, long networks existed already, but not like this. What I find most amazing about these relays is that they were wireless and required lines of sight, which means every array had to be visible to the others
回到20世纪50年代，美国电话电报公司（AT&T）参与了一个巨大的全国性建设项目。该公司在全国范围内部署了整个中继网络。当然，长途网络已经存在，但不是这样的。我发现这些中继最令人惊奇的是它们是无线的，并且需要视线，这意味着每个阵列必须对其他阵列可见
around it in order to relay signals. So these are point-to-point relays and they bounced information from coast to coast across the entire United States. For decades, they connected cities to cities across these vast expanses. You could see them up on mountaintops just everywhere across the country. If you google a map of them, it's really incredible how extensive they were. And now, of course, in the days of fiber optics and satellites, they're basically obsolete. And some of them are long gone. But many are still up, like these ones are no-quit. Alas, one of my favorite sets that I really liked in Minneapolis got taken down recently.
才能中继信号。所以这些是点对点中继，它们将信息从美国海岸传送到海岸。几十年来，它们将城市与城市连接在这些广阔的区域上。你可以在全国各地的山顶上看到它们。如果你谷歌搜索它们的地图，你会发现它们的覆盖范围非常惊人。当然，现在在光纤和卫星时代，它们基本上已经过时了。有些早已不复存在。但许多仍然存在，就像这些一样。唉，我最喜欢的一组在明尼阿波利斯，最近被拆除了。
It formed this kind of crown around the top of this building, downtown. And so you can't go look for that particular one anymore, but you can't see an illustration of it in our book. And some relays are still up because it's just too much hassle to dismantle them. And there's really no reason to. But in other cases, like this tower in Los Angeles, they are factored into the architecture itself. So they're like made to fit into the design of the building. And in part, that makes them harder to spot because you don't really know what they're there for and they could just become an architectural flourish.
它在市中心那栋建筑的顶部形成了一种皇冠。所以你不能再去寻找那一个了，但你可以在我们的书中看到它的插图。有些中继仍然存在，因为拆除它们太麻烦了。而且真的没有理由这样做。但在其他情况下，比如洛杉矶的这座塔，它们被纳入了建筑本身。所以它们像是为了适应建筑的设计而制作的。在某种程度上，这使它们更难被发现，因为你真的不知道它们是干什么用的，它们可能只是成为了一种建筑装饰。
And even in cases where they do stand out more, they're not always easy to see because the tops of buildings are covered with a lot of stuff like each fac systems and satellite dishes. But once you know what you're looking for, you'll just start seeing them everywhere. Most of the numbered streets downtown are one way, which means they have white dashed Most of the numbered streets downtown are one way, which means they have white dashed center lines that divide the lanes. This innovation is credited to one man, Edward Inhines.
即使在它们更突出的情况下，它们也不总是容易看到，因为建筑物的顶部覆盖着很多东西，比如暖通空调系统和卫星天线。但一旦你知道你在找什么，你就会开始到处看到它们。市中心大多数编号的街道都是单向的，这意味着它们有白色虚线
He was a road booster and a member of the Wayne County Road Commission in Michigan in the early 20th century, when cars were just getting more widespread on roads. The story goes, he was driving on a country road behind a milk truck that was leaking its cargo, and this inspired him to invent lane dividing center lines. This always struck me as a ridiculous story. But anyway, however he got the inspiration, thanks to Heinz, the first stripe of paint providing lanes was laid down in Wayne County, which includes Detroit,
中心线划分车道。这一创新归功于一个人，爱德华·海因斯（Edward Hines）。他是20世纪初密歇根州韦恩县道路委员会的成员，当时汽车在道路上越来越普及。故事是这样的，他开车在乡村道路上，跟在一辆漏货的运奶车后面，这启发了他发明了车道划分中心线。这对我来说一直是一个荒谬的故事。但无论如何，不管他是怎么得到灵感的，多亏了海因斯，第一条提供车道的油漆条被铺设在韦恩县，其中包括底特律，
and from there lines began to be drawn through curves and dangerous zones to encourage cars to stick to their side, and those particularly has a response. And then eventually they appeared on all roads in the county and then across the state. Today, roadways across the US feature millions of miles of paint from coast to coast. Hines certainly left an indelible mark on the world, even if that mopedruck story is bullshit. So there's a lot of construction going on right now in Oakland. A lot of sidewalks are torn up or closed down downtown area. A lot of beautiful murals though around, but if you walk down the sidewalk, few blocks from our office, you
从那里开始，线条开始被画在弯道和危险区域，以鼓励汽车保持在自己的一侧，这特别是一种回应。然后最终它们出现在县里的所有道路上，然后遍布全州。今天，美国各地的道路上都有数百万英里的油漆。海因斯确实在世界上留下了不可磨灭的印记，即使那个运奶车的故事是胡扯。所以奥克兰现在有很多建筑工程。市中心有很多路面被挖开或关闭。虽然周围有很多美丽的壁画，但如果你走在人行道上，离我们办公室几个街区，你
can see these little plaques embedded underfoot, and this one is pretty clearly wordy. It says private property, permission to pass over, revocable at any time. Some of them are a bit more cryptic. They say things like space within building lines not dedicated, which can be kind of hard to parse, but the message is the same. It's basically, hey, you can walk here, but just so you know, this is technically private property. Sometimes owners will, you know, build right up to the property line or put landscaping out that marks off the edge of their territory, but when they don't, this is a way for them to maintain their
可以看到这些嵌入脚下的小牌匾，这一个写得很清楚。它写着“私人财产，允许通行，可随时撤销”。有些更隐晦一些。它们写着“建筑线内的空间未专用”，这可能有点难解析，但信息是一样的。基本上是说，嘿，你可以在这里走，但你要知道，这在技术上是私人财产。有时业主会，你知道，直接建到地界线，或者放置标记出他们领土边缘的景观，但当他们不这样做时，这是一种让他们维护
ownership. And so, some install these shiny middle plaques and others just stamp messages like these right into the concrete. And effectively, they're telling you, hey, you're on private property in a place that you might not think is private property. So it might feel like a public sidewalk, but it's not. And if you look down a sidewalk, you can often see a bigger pattern, like a series of these forming a long dashed line. And that of course marks out the property's edge. And then at the corner, you might find a right angled version, and that's of course to mark out the corner of the property. So together, these form an outline of the building
所有权的方式。所以，有些人安装这些闪亮的金属牌匾，而另一些人只是把这样的信息直接印在混凝土上。实际上，他们是在告诉你，嘿，你在一个你可能认为不是私人财产的地方，实际上是在私人财产上。所以它可能感觉像公共人行道，但事实并非如此。如果你往下看人行道，你经常可以看到一个更大的图案，比如一系列形成长虚线的标记。这当然标出了物业的边缘。然后在拐角处，你可能会发现一个直角版本，这当然是为了标出物业的拐角。所以总的来说，这些形成了建筑
property footprint. And they're important for building owners because of something called adverse possession. Now, the laws around this vary from place to place. But the basic idea is that if you don't explicitly reserve your property right somehow, you could lose them. So the easement markers are there in case the owners want to build out later. But in the meantime, they're also conceding some space for semi-public use, which is nice. And once you recognize what these markers signify and start to see them, they'll also start to see open spaces differently. And recognize that there are invisible lines dividing public and private property, or at least invisible until you start reading the blocks.
物业占地面积的轮廓。对于建筑业主来说，它们很重要，因为有一种东西叫“逆权侵占”。现在，关于这一点的法律因地而异。但基本思想是，如果你不以某种方式明确保留你的财产权利，你可能会失去它们。所以地役权标记的存在是为了以防业主以后想扩建。但与此同时，他们也让出了一些空间供半公共使用，这很好。一旦你认识到这些标记代表什么并开始看到它们，你也会开始以不同的方式看待开放空间。并认识到有无形的线条划分公共和私人财产，或者至少在开始阅读这些街区之前是无形的。
Those are just a handful of stories from the 99% invisible city, inspired by the things on our street. When you get the book, you can explore about 400 pages of similar stories. And if you listen to me reading the audiobook, it's about 11 hours. You can put it on at bedtime. You can listen all the way through the night without having to queue up another episode
这些只是《99%隐形城市》中的一小部分故事，灵感来自我们街道上的事物。当你拿到这本书时，你可以探索大约400页类似的故事。如果你听我读有声书，大约有11个小时。你可以在睡前播放。你可以整晚听完，而不必排队播放另一集
or listen to a furniture ad, although I like the furniture ads. It is an interesting time to be alive and an interesting time that we put in out this book since we're not really traveling and generally sticking close to home. This is accidentally a perfect field guide for this moment. It's a guide to the wonder of the built world right in your own neighborhood using examples from all over the globe. Maybe it will be a comfort to you. It was designed to be a good companion and to bring more joy in the world. We're trying to get it out to as many people as possible and expand our little tribe of Black readers, design fanatics, and curious
或者听家具广告，尽管我喜欢家具广告。这是一个有趣的生存时代，也是我们出版这本书的有趣时间，因为我们并没有真正旅行，通常都待在家里。这意外地成为了这一时刻的完美实地指南。这是一本关于你所在社区建筑世界奇迹的指南，使用了来自全球各地的例子。也许它会给你带来安慰。它被设计成一个好的伴侣，并为世界带来更多的快乐。我们正试图把它送到尽可能多的人手中，并扩大我们的小部落，包括黑人读者、设计狂热者和好奇的
urbanists. You can get a copy for yourself and your friends and family at 99pi.org slash book. Coming up, Kurt and I talk about some of the behind the scenes of making the book and answer many questions people have been asking about the process. Stay with us. So I'm talking with Kurt Colestead. He's the digital director of 99% invisible in the co-author of the book. And we want to answer a lot of the questions that we've been asked as we've been putting together the book over the last couple of years. Yeah, and some of these are questions that have come up, you know, over and over again and so I've sort of distilled them down and said, okay, like which ones are the
城市规划者。你可以在 99pi.org/book 为自己和你的朋友家人买一本。接下来，柯克和我将谈论制作这本书的一些幕后花絮，并回答人们一直在问的关于这个过程的许多问题。请继续收听。所以我正在和柯克·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colestead）交谈。他是《99%隐形》的数字总监，也是这本书的合著者。我们想回答我们在过去几年里整理这本书时被问到的许多问题。是的，其中一些是人们一遍又一遍提出的问题，所以我把它们提炼出来，说，好吧，哪些是
ones that people are asking the most? And we came up with these questions that seem to sort of synthesize the things that people are interested in knowing more about. Right. So the first one is about the process of gathering material and picking topics and organizing all of the book. I mean one of the things that we had working for us and against us was the 10 years of the show. So there's a lot of like information, information presented in different ways, tons of stuff that's in the book that you know never appeared on a show before. So let's talk a little bit about how we organize the book. There's this joke I've been telling friends, you know, if you're going to write a book, maybe write it about one thing instead of 100 things. And you know, it's a really unique challenge
人们问得最多的？我们想出了这些问题，似乎综合了人们感兴趣了解更多的事情。对。所以第一个是关于收集材料、选择主题和组织整本书的过程。我的意思是，我们拥有的一个有利和不利的因素是这十年的节目。所以有很多信息，以不同方式呈现的信息，书中有很多东西你以前从未在节目中出现过。所以让我们谈谈我们是如何组织这本书的。我一直在告诉朋友一个笑话，你知道，如果你要写一本书，也许写一件事而不是100件事。你知道，这是一个非常独特的挑战
to try to bring all of these stories together under one roof and to figure out, you know, not just what to include, but how to how to structure the whole thing. Going way back, this is the thing that we first started talking about. Like, my first text file that has the field guide idea sitting in it is from June 2017. We started to think about, okay, how might this work? What kinds of things might we want to include? And I started writing articles and we started doing shows with that in the back of our mind, like which things are recovering or not covering
试图把所有这些故事汇集在一个屋檐下，并弄清楚，你知道，不仅要包括什么，还要弄清楚如何构建整个事情。追溯到很久以前，这是我们第一次开始谈论的事情。就像，我第一个包含实地指南想法的文本文件来自2017年6月。我们开始思考，好吧，这怎么行得通？我们可能想包括什么样的东西？我开始写文章，我们开始在脑海中带着这个想法做节目，比如我们正在报道或没有报道哪些事情
that would make sense to include in a book about cities and design. And then in 2018, we started to really sit down with this thing and we started working on this giant spreadsheet which was a list of every article that you've ever written and every episode that we've ever done and a bunch of ideas on top of that and there were all these different tabs it was this that's a thing it was really something to be hold yeah and And then you and I went through and we raided them on a scale to one to five of what type of things
在关于城市和设计的书中包含这些是有意义的。然后在2018年，我们开始真正坐下来处理这件事，我们开始处理这个巨大的电子表格，它是你写过的每一篇文章和我们做过的每一集的列表，以及除此之外的一堆想法，有所有这些不同的标签，这真的是一件值得一看的事情。是的，然后你和我浏览了一遍，我们给它们打分，从一到五，看看什么类型的东西
would be included in the book that each of us is conceiving in our mind before it had actually been put together. Right. And that was sort of this initial weeding out process whereas like, okay, if you say it's a one and I say it's a five, maybe we should talk about it. But of course there are a lot of places where we just agreed.
会被包含在书中，我们每个人在它真正被组合在一起之前都在脑海中构思。对。这是一种最初的剔除过程，就像，好吧，如果你说它是1，我说它是5，也许我们应该谈谈它。但当然，有很多地方我们只是同意。
It's like, well, this has to be in the book. Right. This is a story we need to tell. And one of the ways that I've explained it to other people too is, you know, you had this idea, and maybe I'm oversimplifying a little, but you had this idea of including the best possible stories, which is a great idea. I had this idea of making sure it all made sense as a book, making sure there were sort of arcs within stories, but also between stories and sections and chapters.
就像，好吧，这必须在书中。对。这是一个我们需要讲述的故事。我向其他人解释它的方式之一也是，你知道，你有这个想法，也许我有点简化了，但你有包括尽可能最好的故事的想法，这是一个好主意。我有确保它作为一本书都有意义的想法，确保故事内部以及故事、部分和章节之间有某种弧线。
I think that tension was actually a really productive tension. You were checking me on, are you just trying to fit this in because you kind of want it to make more sense as a bigger thing? Or is it actually a good story? Yeah, one of the other tensions was this idea of like how much to be a field guide that related to what was happening in most cities
我认为这种张力实际上是一种非常有成效的张力。你在检查我，你是只是想把它塞进去，因为你有点想让它作为一个更大的东西更有意义吗？还是它真的是一个好故事？是的，另一个张力是关于如何成为一本与大多数城市正在发生的事情相关的实地指南的想法
and how much to tell, you know, the best and most interesting story possible. And I think we walked the line really well, but it was definitely something we thought about each step of the way. Like I have a particular affinity for kind of the most interesting story about the most every day or mundane thing. Like that's my favorite version of this. That's kind of the heart of the field guide as a concept. But there's so many things that don't quite fit into that that we just were just excited about, you know, like, especially new things. Like, when you would come back with some research about stuff that, you know, we never covered in the show,
以及讲述，你知道，尽可能最好和最有趣的故事。我认为我们走得很好，但这绝对是我们每一步都在思考的事情。比如我对关于最日常或平凡事物的最有趣的故事有一种特殊的亲和力。就像那是这个版本我最喜欢的。这在某种程度上是实地指南作为概念的核心。但有太多东西不太适合那样，我们只是对它们感到兴奋，你知道，比如，特别是新东西。比如，当你带回一些关于东西的研究时，你知道，我们从未在节目中报道过，
those were my favorite because I often get, you know, like, if I've covered it, I'm like, I'm like, I know, I know it already. And so, like, when he came back with like Batonberg and various other things, like, that was really the type of thing that I was really, really jazzed about when it came to putting the book together. And for me too, as a person who is a fan of the show for years before I joined the show, there were some fun in revisiting old stories and looking at the raw material and looking what it happened since those stories were published and sort of rethinking it all for the book and you know like the Chicago River comes to mind and you know we talked about the Chicago River or you did in a in an old episode. Yeah that was
那些是我最喜欢的，因为我经常得到，你知道，比如，如果我已经报道过它，我会说，我知道，我已经知道了。所以，当他带回像巴滕伯格（Battenberg）和各种其他东西时，就像，那真的是我在把书放在一起时真正感到兴奋的那种东西。对我来说，作为一个在加入节目之前多年来一直是节目粉丝的人，重温旧故事并查看原始材料，看看这些故事发布后发生了什么，并为这本书重新思考这一切，这很有趣，你知道，比如芝加哥河浮现在脑海中，你知道我们谈论过芝加哥河，或者你在旧节目中谈论过。是的，那是
one we did a years ago with Dan Weisman. But you know in the book we talk about it in a different way you know I found some more history to that. That was kind of fun and interesting. And so we ended up within the book with this kind of combination of some things drawn from the episode, some sort of new developments in the case, and then some more history, too. So it's fun for me to dive back into some of the classics
我们几年前和丹·韦斯曼（Dan Weisman）一起做的。但你知道在书中，我们以不同的方式谈论它，你知道我为它找到了一些更多的历史。这很有趣，也很有意思。所以我们最终在书中结合了一些从剧集中提取的东西，一些案例中的新发展，然后还有一些更多的历史。所以对我来说，潜回一些经典作品中很有趣
and expand on that material as well. Yeah, and it really is a different thing to create a book versus to create a story for a podcast. You know, a lot of people ask us about like how it differs like with audio storytelling in terms of structure and approach. When you're writing for audio, you know that it's linear, you know that people are only hearing it, you know it in order once, and they're not sort of scanning it the same way that they do when it comes to written text. And so there's this process of reiterating the point, you know, anecdote and reflection, anecdote and reflection, and reiterating a point.
并扩展这些材料。是的，创作一本书与为播客创作一个故事确实是不同的事情。你知道，很多人问我们关于它在结构和方法上与音频叙事有何不同。当你为音频写作时，你知道它是线性的，你知道人们只是在听它，你知道它按顺序听一次，他们不像阅读书面文本那样扫描它。所以有一个重申观点的过程，你知道，轶事和反思，轶事和反思，以及重申一个观点。
And it is something that it does not work in text. And it was something that was really clear when we started working with Kate, our editor at HMH. She really helped guide and put us in a direction towards a more written format. It was just learning a new skill, especially for me, for sure. Oh, for me too. And just the leveling up that happened
这是在文本中行不通的东西。当我们开始与我们的编辑凯特（Kate）在HMH工作时，这一点非常清楚。她真的帮助指导并引导我们走向更书面的格式。这只是学习一项新技能，特别是对我来说，当然。哦，对我来说也是。随着我们更多地参与其中，并让他们更多地参与这个过程，所发生的升级
as we got more involved with them and involved them more in the process. So for us, we started out writing essays and it started to graduate towards sections, but you know, soon enough, we were sending these essays and sections to the editor and getting feedback at the kind of granular level. And then it took a long time to kind of build that up into these larger chapters. And each stage of the review, it was like we would send something bigger and wait a little longer, but get more feedback. But fortunately, early on in the process, we did get a lot of guidance from them about
对我们来说，我们开始写文章，它开始向部分过渡，但你知道，很快，我们就把这些文章和部分发送给编辑，并在某种程度上获得反馈。然后花了很长时间才把它建立成这些更大的章节。在审查的每个阶段，就像我们会发送更大的东西并等待更长时间，但获得更多反馈。但幸运的是，在过程的早期，我们确实从他们那里得到了很多关于
what does and doesn't work in a book, which helped us decide, you know, how are we going to tie different stories together? It turned out I had this idea early on that, you know, each story would really clearly dovetail the next. Yeah, and they did not want that. Kate was just like, no, people will not read it that way. I remember each one, we, you and I, like, labored over these hand-off final sentences that would lead right to the next essay. And Kate, Kate Napolitano, who was like a fantastic editor, who did amazing work with us, you know, was kind of just like, you don't need to do this.
书中什么行得通，什么行不通的指导，这帮助我们决定，你知道，我们将如何把不同的故事联系在一起？事实证明，我早期有这个想法，你知道，每个故事都会非常清楚地与下一个故事衔接。是的，他们不想要那样。凯特只是说，不，人们不会那样读它。我记得每一个，我们，你和我，就像，在这些会导致下一篇文章的交接最后一句上费尽心思。而凯特·纳波利塔诺（Kate Napolitano），她是一位出色的编辑，和我们一起做了了不起的工作，你知道，只是说，你不需要这样做。
Like, if they're going to read the next one, they're going to read the next one. If they're not, and if you really mean it, that people can skip around and read different parts, then it just doesn't help. And it was like, oh yeah, I guess you're right. But I remember, like, we had all, I'm. And it was like, oh yeah, I guess you're right. But I remember like we had all, I'm trying to think of like, if there was one type of sentence
就像，如果他们要读下一篇，他们就会读下一篇。如果他们不读，如果你真的是认真的，人们可以跳着读不同的部分，那么它就没用了。就像，哦，是的，我想你是对的。但我记得，就像，我们有所有，我。就像，哦，是的，我想你是对的。但我记得就像我们有所有，我试图想出，如果有一种句子
most consistently cut, it was probably one of these like pithy handoff sentences that leads directly to the first paragraph of the next essay. Right. And we ended up with a kind of compromise where it's like, if you do keep reading, you will connect the dots. We're not going to connect those dots for you. But if you're reading straight through, you'll see, it's like a little Easter egg, you know, like you're reading straight
最一致地被删减，那可能就是这些直接导致下一篇文章第一段的简洁交接句之一。对。我们最终达成了一种妥协，就像，如果你继续读，你会把点连起来。我们不会为你连接这些点。但如果你一直读下去，你会看到，这就像一个小彩蛋，你知道，就像你一直读下去
through, you'll catch on to the connections between these different pieces. But you're not kind of forced to read straight through in order to make those connections either, and you can jump around. Exactly. Exactly. And that whole process, everything about the process, A, was I think pretty smooth. It was like a really good, they were good collaborators in a sense. But one of the things that was just really different was the timeline of a book. I mean, like, you know, we do a show every week. It takes maybe six to eight weeks to
读下去，你就能领会到这些不同片段之间的联系。但你也不必非得按顺序从头读到尾才能建立这些联系，你可以跳着读。没错。确实如此。整个过程，关于这个过程的一切，A，我认为都相当顺利。从某种意义上说，他们是非常好的合作者。但有一件事确实非常不同，那就是书的进度安排。我的意思是，你知道，我们每周都要做一期节目。制作一期节目可能需要六到八周的时间，
make an episode of the show. So there's always this constant turn. You put out articles, you know, like there was a little bit less of them when you are working on the book. Yeah, I had to set some of that aside a little bit. Of course, which you needed to, but you consistently over the years have put out two or three articles a week. Sometimes, you know, so we're very used to a production process that has a different metabolism than that of a book creation. Having a long deadline that's really far in the future, like what happens with the book is terrible. And what makes it almost excruciating
所以总是处于不断的轮转中。你会发布文章，你知道，当你写书的时候，文章的数量会少一些。是的，我不得不把其中的一些工作暂时搁置。当然，这是必须的，但多年来你一直保持着每周发布两到三篇文章的频率。有时，你知道，所以我们非常习惯于一种与书籍创作完全不同的新陈代谢节奏的生产流程。有一个遥远的截止日期，就像写书那样，这真的很糟糕。而最让人痛苦的是，
is having a weekly deadline that runs in parallel to that deadline. Well, the only way the long deadline of the book worked really was to break it down to the shorter deadlines and to say, okay, well, we're going to have a version of chapter one by X and a version of chapter two by why it's like, where do you start? How do you find the kind of motivation to do this if you don't?
还要同时面对一个每周的截止日期。嗯，书的长期截止日期唯一行得通的方法就是把它拆解成更短的截止日期，并说，好吧，我们要在X时间前完成第一章的版本，在Y时间前完成第二章的版本。这就像是，你从哪里开始呢？如果你不这样做，你怎么找到做这件事的动力呢？
And yet, one of the surprises to me, I mean, I look back and I think it's so silly, but I told, you know, friends and family towards the end of 2019, I'm like, well, we're almost through the hard part. And it seems so naive in hindsight. It's just, it's a process and it keeps going. And as soon as you're done with one thing, you've got to kind of move on to the next, whether it's working with the illustrator and working with the designer, there's always something to be done.
然而，让我感到惊讶的是，我回过头来看，觉得这太傻了，但在2019年底，我告诉朋友和家人，我说，好吧，我们快熬过最难的部分了。现在回想起来，这显得太天真了。这只是一个过程，而且它还在继续。一旦你完成了一件事，你就得继续做下一件事，无论是与插画师合作还是与设计师合作，总有事情要做。
And the text is part of that. And the text is a key part of that. But it isn't all of it for sure. I mean, there's a map by a lot of it. Just deciding on illustrations and in design and color and the printing and the or, you know, just everything about it was just so complicated. And one of those things that we were really involved in, because one of the pitfalls of having to show about design
文字只是其中的一部分。文字确实是其中的关键部分。但肯定不是全部。我的意思是，很大一部分是地图。仅仅是决定插图、设计、颜色、印刷，或者，你知道，关于它的一切都太复杂了。这是我们真正参与的事情之一，因为做一个关于设计的节目，陷阱之一就是
is that the book you make better be good. You don't like it better. Yeah. Yeah, it's better to look good. It better read well, it better flow. It better have a reason for existing. That was my main thing. It's like, I already get the opportunity
你做出来的书最好要好。你不会希望它不好。是的。是的，它最好看起来不错。它最好读起来通顺，最好有流畅感。它最好有存在的理由。这是我的主要考量。就像是，我已经有机会
to tell millions of people stories about design. So why should a book exist? And what can it do that the show can't do? And that's something that we were constantly thinking about of how to exploit those differences between a book and a podcast and a website. And so all those things required so much thought, I mean, so much so that I think HMH was shocked at the level of detail, especially you were writing them with. Well, yeah, I mean, I think they expected, you know, they're used to authors, authors are authoring, right? They're writing, they're doing the tech stuff. But of course, you know, we're interested in design.
向数百万人讲述关于设计的故事。那么为什么还需要一本书呢？它能做些什么节目做不到的事情？这是我们一直在思考的问题，即如何利用书、播客和网站之间的差异。所以所有这些事情都需要深思熟虑，我的意思是，以至于我认为HMH出版社对细节的程度感到震惊，尤其是你们写作的方式。嗯，是的，我的意思是，我认为他们预料到，你知道，他们习惯了作者，作者就是作者，对吧？他们在写作，他们在做技术工作。但当然，你知道，我们对设计很感兴趣。
So we want to work with the designer, we want to work with the illustrator, we want to, you know, make this a designed object. And I have this background in architecture. And so I'm not a great designer, but I, but I at least like the process and know how it works. And so a lot of it was sort of navigating this challenging thing, which you always have to navigate with designers, which is to say, figure out what their strengths are. So we spent, for example, a lot of time looking at the portfolios of both Patrick Vale and Rafael Geroni, who are the illustrator and designer of the book, and saying, okay, how
所以我们想和设计师合作，我们想和插画师合作，我们想，你知道，让它成为一个经过设计的对象。我有建筑学的背景。所以我不是一个伟大的设计师，但我至少喜欢这个过程，并且知道它是如何运作的。所以很大程度上是在处理这种具有挑战性的事情，你总是必须与设计师沟通，也就是说，找出他们的优势所在。例如，我们花了很多时间查看Patrick Vale和Rafael Geroni的作品集，他们是这本书的插画师和设计师，并说，好吧，我们如何
can we lean into their strengths? How can we sort of give them the freedom to do what they do well? But make sure we also cover the things that we need to cover in the course of this design process. Yeah. So, when we went through and took every story we've ever told in whatever format and put it into a big spreadsheet and ranked them from one to five about what to include in the book,
利用他们的优势？我们如何给他们自由去发挥他们的专长？但同时确保我们在设计过程中涵盖我们需要涵盖的内容。是的。所以，当我们回顾并把我们讲过的每一个故事，无论什么格式，都放进一个大电子表格中，并按一到五的等级对它们进行排名，以决定哪些内容要包含在书中时，
we both quickly settled on the first one being the official graffiti. It had an explosion, it seemed like a good thing that people would see everywhere that was a story behind it. We could teach people how to decode it in ways that were really fun and obvious. And so I remember that being kind of one of the first ones we settled on, this leads me to one of the last ones we included.
我们很快都确定第一篇应该是官方涂鸦。它有一个爆炸点，看起来像是一个人们随处可见且背后有故事的好东西。我们可以教人们如何以非常有趣和显而易见的方式解读它。所以我记得那是我们最早确定的篇章之一，这让我想到了我们收录的最后一篇。
So there was a drama in San Francisco with these boulders, which is in chapter six, which is really the last story that we included at all. And I remember you asking me, like, like, is this worth it? You know, like you, pretty bedrackled and tired from the other 400 pages, right? It was probably, it just felt like, like I also was worried, I was like,
在旧金山有一些关于这些巨石的戏剧性事件，在第六章中，这确实是我们收录的最后一个故事。我记得你问我，就像，这值得吗？你知道，就像你，从另外400页的内容中走出来，已经筋疲力尽了，对吧？这可能，只是感觉就像，我也很担心，我当时想，
is the publisher gonna say, guys, you have to stop adding it? Please. So, it's like, you know, can we, can we convince them to just sneak this one last piece in? and it sort of encapsulated so much of what we were talking about already in chapter six that it was just like, yeah, I think we got to do it. And one of the questions that we've gotten asked to is, you know, what's your favorite piece? And that's hard to nail down. I really like the first piece in the book. I do think it sort of captures the essence of the book really well. sort of captures the essence of the book really well. But in some ways, some of my favorite pieces are the ones I had to fight for. Yeah.
出版商会不会说，伙计们，你们得停止添加内容了？拜托。所以，就像是，你知道，我们能说服他们把这最后一部分塞进去吗？它确实概括了我们在第六章中已经讨论过的很多内容，所以感觉就是，是的，我想我们必须这样做。我们被问到的问题之一也是，你知道，你最喜欢哪一篇？这很难确定。我真的很喜欢书中的第一篇。我确实认为它很好地捕捉到了这本书的精髓。确实很好地捕捉到了这本书的精髓。但在某些方面，我最喜欢的一些篇章是我不得不争取保留下来的。
So, there was some consideration of cutting a few pieces, one of which was the piece about standardized time. Right. Right. This was the story of how different towns had to finally start coordinating their clocks because the train was coming and they had to get on the same schedule. What I realized sort of going back over it is that it wasn't super clear, it was probably too long. I could see how it wasn't working, but I really thought that the ideas in it were
所以，当时考虑过删减一些篇章，其中之一就是关于标准化时间的篇章。对。对。这是关于不同的城镇如何最终开始协调他们的时钟的故事，因为火车要来了，他们必须统一时间表。我回过头来看，意识到它写得不够清晰，可能太长了。我能看出它为什么行不通，但我真的认为其中的观点是
worth keeping and that it was a story worth telling just in shorter form. Yeah. And so it became one of my favorites because it became one I had to work on in order to justify keeping it in the book basically. Yeah. I do remember us sitting at my kitchen table and us going over that one and me being one of the naysayers who just was like, this is too complicated. Like people are not, people can't do math in this, in this way. And asking you questions about like, why is this important? And having you, you know, obviously just come through with it. And I remember, you know, like I've more recently, you know, had the deep dive with the book because I've been reading it, you know, in,
值得保留的，而且这是一个值得以更短的形式讲述的故事。是的。所以它成了我最喜欢的篇章之一，因为它成了我为了证明将其保留在书中而不得不努力修改的篇章。是的。我确实记得我们坐在我的厨房桌子旁，我们一起过了一遍那一篇，而我是那些反对者之一，当时觉得，这太复杂了。就像人们不会，人们无法以这种方式进行数学运算。并问你一些关于，为什么这很重要的问题？让你，你知道，显然是把它讲通了。而且我记得，你知道，就像我最近，你知道，对这本书进行了深入研究，因为我一直在读它，你知道，在
in the studio out loud. And that's a great section. It really works. Like you did a great job making that relevant and not complicated and make people understand what it really meant to standardize time when this was not a concern of people at all for millennia. Yeah, and I remember that conversation too, and it was like, I needed, I got it.
工作室里大声朗读。那是一个很棒的部分。它真的很有效。你做得很好，让它变得相关且不复杂，让人们理解当这在几千年来根本不是人们关心的问题时，标准化时间到底意味着什么。是的，我也记得那次谈话，就像是，我需要，我明白了。
Like I understood why I was so attached to it. But I needed some way, I basically needed you to talk to and you just say, okay, it just explained it to me. Like don't read it, just explain it to me. And once I did, you saw the kind of passion I had for it. I think we both realized, okay, there's something here. It's just not fully on the page right now. So it's like, we got to go back to the drawing board a bit and figure out how to simplify this and streamline this so that it's just a compelling story. And that's what we tried to do for every story
就像我理解为什么我如此依恋它。但我需要某种方式，我基本上需要你和我谈谈，你只是说，好吧，把它解释给我听。就像不要读它，只是解释给我听。一旦我这样做了，你就看到了我对它的那种热情。我想我们都意识到，好吧，这里面确实有些东西。只是现在还没有完全呈现在页面上。所以就像是，我们必须回到绘图板上，想办法简化它并精简它，使它成为一个引人入胜的故事。这就是我们为每一个故事所尝试做的，
over and over again, page after page, while putting this book together. And it comes out today. First of all, I wanna thank Kurt Colestead for working so hard on every aspect of this book, his talent and attention to detail is unparalleled. And I also want to thank the 99PI team for reporting so many of the original stories we've been told and also taking up the slack when we had our heads down trying to power through
一遍又一遍，一页又一页，在整理这本书的时候。它今天出版了。首先，我要感谢Kurt Colestead在本书的各个方面所付出的辛勤工作，他的才华和对细节的关注是无与伦比的。我也要感谢99PI团队报道了我们讲述的许多原创故事，并在我们埋头苦干试图完成
the writing and the editing. And I want to thank you, you beautiful nerds, for supporting us this far. And buying copies for all your friends and family. It's a really good book for nerdy dads. You got nerdy dad, and that's a good book for him. I say this as a nerdy dad. You should skip giving him the biography of some more War II general this year and give him this book instead. All the pre-orders up to this point
写作和编辑工作时承担了额外的工作。我要感谢你们，这些可爱的书呆子们，支持我们走到这一步。并为你们所有的朋友和家人购买副本。这是一本非常适合书呆子老爸的书。你有书呆子老爸，那对他来说是一本好书。我作为一个书呆子老爸这么说。今年你应该跳过送他某位二战将军的传记，而是送他这本书。到目前为止所有的预购
and the sales from this week, summed together to give us our place on the best seller charts. I really wanna be on the best seller charts. So this is the Time to Act. Get your copy today at 9iMPI.org slash book. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Kurt Coleset, Music by Sean Raell.
加上本周的销售额，加在一起让我们在畅销书排行榜上占有一席之地。我真的很想上畅销书排行榜。所以现在是行动的时候了。今天就在99pi.org/book购买你的副本。本周的99% Invisible由Kurt Coleset制作，音乐由Sean Raell创作。
Delaney Hall is the senior producer. The rest of the team is Chris Barouba, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Sophia Klotzger Miller, Vivian Leigh, Abby Madon, Katie Mingle, Joe Rosenberg, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 99.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row, which is scattered across the North American continent, but we will always be centered. And beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California.
Delaney Hall是高级制作人。团队的其他成员是Chris Barouba、Emmett Fitzgerald、Christopher Johnson、Sophia Klotzger Miller、Vivian Leigh、Abby Madon、Katie Mingle、Joe Rosenberg，以及我Roman Mars。我们是旧金山99.7K ALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作，它分散在北美大陆，但我们将永远以加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心为中心。
We are a founding member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative listeners supported 100% artist-owned podcasts in the world. Fun Mall at radiotopia.fm. You can tweet me with pictures of the book and the coin at Roman Mars and the show at 9.9 PIorg. You can share pictures of the book and the coin at Roman Mars and the show at 99pi org. You can share pictures of the book and the coin on Instagram and read it too. But the one place I would love for you to go to get your copy of the 99% visible city if you haven't done it already is 99pi.org. Slashbook. Radio TMP from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是来自PRX的Radio Topia的创始成员，这是一个由世界上最具创新性的听众支持的、100%艺术家拥有的播客组成的激烈独立的集体。详情请访问radiotopia.fm。你可以用书和硬币的照片在Twitter上@Roman Mars，并@99pi.org关注节目。你可以在Instagram和Reddit上分享书和硬币的照片。但如果你还没有购买，我最希望你去购买《99% Invisible City》的地方是99pi.org/book。来自PRX的Radio Topia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。